Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Durchfällt dir langsam den Bezug zur Normalität?
Also wenn die Normalität hier die Gülle chaoten sind mit ihren Diesel-Demos,
die den Straßenverkehr versperren, dann kann ich das verstehen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 480 vom 23.
Dezember 2023 und ja, wie schon angedeutet, machen wir doch noch eine Sendung.
Letztes Mal haben wir ja von der letzten Sendung geredet.
Das war natürlich die letzte Sendung dieses Jahres gemeint. Keine Angst,
liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir machen auch im nächsten Jahr weiter.
Da gibt es keinerlei Pläne, hier irgendwas einzustellen.
Aber jetzt genießen wir die Ruhe. Und ich weiß nicht, wie geht es dir so um
Weihnachten herum in Berlin?
Also ich finde das immer ganz schön, wenn alles so ein bisschen runtergefahren
ist bisschen mehr Schnee wäre noch ganz gut, aber das wird ja wahrscheinlich
jetzt nichts wegen der Bauern und,
ja es gibt mehr Parkplätze Ich hatte ein bisschen Bahnspaß die letzten Tage, also.
Das bisschen Wind hat schon gereicht, um mich irgendwie stranden zu lassen,
irgendwo spontan im Hotel, weil eine Weitereise nicht zu erwarten ist und so.
So viele auf den Gleisen.
Ja, und dann nachher Menschen in den Zügen. Ich habe dann am nächsten Tag einfach
einen Platz nach dem anderen reserviert.
Du musst ja dann gucken, dass du in den Zug auch einen Sitzplatz kriegst.
Ich hatte relativ viel Gepäck.
Und dann stand ich in Hannover, hier in deiner Stadt Hannover,
dich ja so begeistert, dann stand ich am Bahnhof und ich dachte dann so,
boah, ey, da waren dann wirklich so viele Leute, wo du denkst,
boah, der ICE, das wird gleich ein Riesenspaß.
Und dann hatte ich, hab ich gedacht, boah, wenn jetzt irgendwie,
sagen wir mal, so eine alte Frau, oder ein alter Mann auf meinem Platz sitzt,
weil das war alles voll mit Rentnern.
Und ich dachte, oh shit, Die hatten da alles aufgefahren.
So gingen alle am Stock und Rollstuhl und weißer Stock.
Und da war wirklich alles vertreten.
Und ich hatte halt meine Reservierung und war total happy. Ich dachte so,
boah, wenn jetzt gleich jemand auf meinem Platz sitzt und dann kann ich jetzt nicht zu einem...
Das ist so ein rollendes Pflegeheim.
Und dann denkst du halt so, scheiße, ey. und dann gehe ich in den Waggon rein
und da sitzen, gucke mich auch alles nur so gebrochene, kranke Leute,
also alte Leute, die du jetzt nicht wegscheuchen kannst und im ganzen Waggon
sitzt so ein jüngischer Typ und ich denke so, warte, kommt hin,
das könnte kommen, das ist ein ausländisches Waggon und sie so,
das ist ja Platz 33 und ich so, ha!
So, pst, verbiss dich, ich hab den Platz reserviert und dann hab ich da hingesetzt,
das hat mir den Tag so richtig versüßt ja, aber sonst,
marginale Wetterschwankungen haben da zu einem Verkehrschaos in Deutschland
geführt War denn da so ein fett Sturm im Westen?
War wohl fett Sturm also mein Schirm war nach einer Minute draußen kaputt gut,
das war jetzt aber auch nur so ein Billigschirm von Rossmann,
dann hatten sie doch irgendwo Wasser gewesen in Hamburg oder so Ich empfehle
dir Regenschirme von Sens.
Die gehen nicht kaputt.
Ich empfehle Ibis Hotel am Bahnhof. Das war am Ende wirklich das Beste.
Klar, aber wenn man nicht immer gerade ein Hotel dabei hat.
Boah, ich hatte irgendwie wirklich, aber ich hatte auch so ein bisschen Weihnachtsgeschenke
und so dabei und das war alles schwer und das war eine Katastrophe.
Dein Leben ist so hart, Linus. Ich fühle mit dir, das ist wirklich dein First
World Problems sind niederschmetternd. Ja, völlig.
Wir müssen auch kurz was zu den Gülle-Chaoten sagen.
Ja, die haben ja angeblich auch alles versperrt. Habe ich nichts von mitbekommen. Ich war nicht da.
Ich habe Bilder gesehen, wo die ganze Straße des 17. Juni zugestellt haben.
Ich wollte nur darauf aufmerksam machen.
Ehrlich gesagt kann ich nicht genau, also ich kann gerade, weil ich mich mit
der Landwirtschaftspolitik nicht auseinandersetze, ich kann gerade gar nicht
die Legitimität, Unlegitimität, Illegitimität oder Überzogenheit dieses Protestes beurteilen.
Ich fand es, insofern möchte ich den gar nicht in Misskredit ziehen,
ein Themenfeld, mit dem ich mich nicht so auskenne.
Mir fällt nur auf, dass die, weißt du, wenn da so ein Bagger steht mit einem
Galgen dran und an dem Galgen hängt eine Ampel, dann wird applaudiert.
Aber wenn irgendein 14-Jähriger mit einer orangen Weste auf der Straße sitzt,
dann ist irgendwie der Untergang des Abendlandes.
Da ist mir aufgefallen, dass es da Unterschiede in der Beurteilung gibt,
in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung.
Geringfügig, kann man so sagen.
Aber der Unterschied ist, das eine war angemeldet und das andere nicht.
Ah, so. Ja. Okay.
Man muss halt für die Revolution nach wie vor eine Bahnsteigkarte kaufen in
Deutschland und das machen die Bauern halt richtig.
Und dann gab es noch ein sehr schönes Video, das habe ich gerade noch gesehen,
da hatte die Polizei sich bemüht, den Zugang zur Autobahn zu verwehren,
indem sie ein Polizeiauto quer auf diese Straße gestellt haben,
aber mit so einem Trecker.
Ist das natürlich jetzt nicht so ein Problem, mal eben durch den Graben zu fahren oder so.
Ganz grundsätzlich habe ich ja auch positive Bezüge zu Treckerprotesten,
zum Beispiel im Wendland gibt es ja auch regelmäßig Treckerproteste oder gab
es dann regelmäßig die Treckerproteste bei den Castortransporten und so.
Das ist schon ein beeindruckendes Demo-Tool. Ja, so ein Trecker.
Also wir fassen zusammen, auch beim zivilen Gehorsam gilt am Ende das Recht des Stärkeren.
Und wir brauchen einfach mehr so Elektro-Trecker.
Hast du wirklich ziviler Gehorsam oder wolltest du ziviler Ungehorsam?
Also ich finde ziviler Gehorsam sehr schön.
Entschuldigung.
Ungehorsam, ja, ziviler Gehorsam.
Ziviler Gehorsam.
Also stimmt, beim zivilen Gehorsam gilt das rechte Stärke. Das ist absolut richtig.
Siehst du mal, das Weihnachten, das macht einen ganz wirr.
So, und wir wollten hier eine Sendung machen.
Insofern würde ich sagen, kommen wir doch zum Feedback. Gab es nämlich wieder.
Wenig überraschend, weil wir haben ja knifflige Themen angesprochen.
Die Sachen, die den Leuten wirklich wichtig sind. Gaming.
Und das erste Feedback ging um Battle Royale von Player Unknown.
Battle Royale von Tim wusste ich schon aus der Freakshow, dass er kein Gamer
ist. Linus hat dich diesbezüglich seither als Verdachtsfall geführt.
Im Zusammenhang,
Ja, weißt du, bis unter Beobachtung, Linus.
Leute, ich habe Epic Pinball. Epic Pinball ist für mich die Definition von Epic Mega Games.
So ein Gamer bin ich. Auf MS-DOS wir haben unsere Spiele noch mit Kommandozeilen gestartet.
Von Disketten.
Aber dann irgendwann bin ich ein bisschen älter geworden, habe ich mich mich
damit tatsächlich nicht mehr so sehr befasst.
Ja, ich hatte auch eine kurze Gaming-Phase, die habe ich dann gegen Poemieren,
getauscht. Wie auch immer.
Im Zusammenhang mit eurer Diskussion der juristischen Auseinandersetzung Epic
Games vs. Google hat sich dieser Verdacht nun erhärtet.
Bei Battle Royale handelt es sich um ein Spielgenre für Multiplayer-Games.
Fortnite Battle Royale und jetzt geht's los PUBG, wovor steht das denn eigentlich?
Player Unknowns,
Player Unknowns Ultimate Battleground ist doch PUBG, oder?
Deswegen heißt es auch der kommentierende Player Unknown.
Okay. Naja gut, also oder Unknown Battlegrounds? Player Unknowns Battlegrounds. Ah ja, okay, gut.
Also sind zwei Vertreter dieses Genres Nur Fortnite ist von Epic Games.
Das Spielprinzip bei Battle-Royale-Spielen besteht darin, dass eine bestimmte
Anzahl von Spielern, zum Beispiel 100, in einer Spielarena gegeneinander antreten.
Wer als letztes übrig bleibt, hat gewonnen.
Zentrales Element dabei ist,
dass sich die Spielarena im Laufe des Spiels immer weiter verkleinert.
Dadurch werden die verbleibenden Spieler auf engeren Raum konzentriert und letztlich
verhindert, dass die Spiele zu lange dauern.
Ja, habe ich übrigens auch, also habe ich den Eindruck gemacht,
dass ich das nicht als Genre, also ich habe einfach nur gesagt,
dass das Fortnite, was du erwähnt hast, Fortnite Battle Royale hieß.
Stand so in der Wikipedia. Mehr kann ich ja nicht machen. Hat auch Christian schon angemerkt.
Hat Apple Wikipedia gesperrt? Dann möchte ich noch beisteuern,
dass der Name sich von dem gleichnamigen japanischen dystopischen Film ableitet,
bei dem Teenager auf eine Insel verfrachtet werden, wo sie ausgesetzt werden
und gegeneinander bis zum Tod kämpfen müssen.
Träschig, aber unterhaltsam. Hunger Games ist aus meiner Sicht ein lahmsmöchtegern Plagiat davon.
Das wusste ich in der Tat noch nicht.
Nee, aber ist das jetzt Film? Okay, Film heißt, es ist immer noch eine Fiktion.
Das weiß man ja bei japanischen Produktionen auch nicht.
Könnte ja auch durchaus einfach sein, dass die eine schrumpfende Insel haben
und da ein paar Teenager drauf tun, die sich irgendwie durchschlagen müssen.
Das ist vorstellbar. Ja.
Naja, also ich meine, machen wir uns nichts vor. Also wir sind jetzt wirklich
beide nicht so in den Gaming-Welten und dass das dann Leute immer so verletzt,
wenn wir die Details nicht am Start haben.
Das tut uns natürlich furchtbar leid, aber es ist einfach weiß ich nicht,
also ich hab nie so die Bereitschaft gehabt, da zu viel Zeit drin zu verlieren,
weil mir das immer nicht wie soll man es sagen, nicht so produktiv vorkam.
Kann ich nur zustimmen. Gleichzeitig hab ich, also ich find das nicht,
falsch und ich schlecht sich mal mit so einem Spiel Auseinanderzusetzen und
ein paar Spiele habe ich auch auf der Playstation 4 gespielt.
Ich hatte mir so eine Playstation 4 gekauft, primär weil ich GTA 5 spielen wollte.
Und das war auch richtig geil. Also GTA 5 habe ich gespielt.
Das ist das, wo man alle Autos klauen und alle umbringen muss, ne?
GTA 5 hat wirklich einen richtig geilen Plot und das ist ein kulturelles Meisterwerk.
Das war wirklich spitze. Also das will man eigentlich schon machen,
GTA 5 spielen. Das war interessant und das war auch ausreichend abwechslungsreich, unterhaltsam.
Da kann man auf jeden Fall sagen,
das war produktiver als jetzt eine Netflix-Serie runterbingen oder so.
Das hat schon Spaß gemacht. macht. Und ein paar andere Spiele habe ich auch gespielt.
Allerdings dieses Battle Royale, das ist ein relativ einfaches Spielprinzip,
wurde ja auch jetzt glaube ich beschrieben,
wo man dann nur ballert und da eigentlich nicht viel passiert,
das empfinde ich dann auf Dauer nicht ganz so meiner Zeit hier angemessen.
Aber wenn wir das jetzt sagen, dann sind wir im nächsten Kommentar wegen Gamershaming dran.
Bitte lasst uns einfach nur nur auch nicht geben.
Und die Dance Moves, die Dance Moves, ich meine, die können wir natürlich hier
im Podcast nicht so richtig ausspielen, aber das habe ich auch noch mitbekommen,
das ist bei Fortnite auch ein ganz tolles Ding.
Hat da irgendein Kind dann diese Spielehersteller verklagt, weil er den Tanz zuerst gemacht hat?
Diesen einen Tanz.
Es gibt irgendeinen Tanz.
Ja.
Der kam dann bei einem dieser Spiele. Und da hat dann eine Mutter von so einem
Kind geklagt, weil das Kind diesen Tanz zuerst aufgeführt hat.
Oh Gott. Und dann alle verfolgt wurden.
Ein Amerikaner. Mal gucken, wie dieser Lawsuit ausgegangen ist.
Fortnite Dance Dance Moves, ja, Fortnite. Ja.
Und da hat der ein, ja, genau, ein Tanzplagiat in Fortnite.
Ist nicht mehr zu fassen. Leute, wirklich, ey. Es geht doch nur ums Geld.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, ich muss zugeben, ich war schon immer etwas erstaunt über
so bestimmte Dynamiken, die durch Spiele so aufgebracht wurden.
Also, dass man sich dadurch refinanzieren kann, In-Game-Clothing zu verkaufen und so weiter.
Das ging, glaube ich, damals, ging das nicht schon mit Second Life irgendwie los oder irgendwie so?
War das nicht so diese Zeit? Also, wo dieses ganze Avatar-Tuning...
Wie heißt das eine, was die da immer spielen?
Egal. In vielen Games Bei Games ist das ja so. Ultima Online?
Ich glaube auch bei Fortnite wurde damit auch viel Geld gemacht.
Da hast du halt irgendwie Kleidung, dann hast du irgendwie Ausrüstung und dieses
und jenes und World of Warcraft war wahrscheinlich auch ganz viel davon.
Genau, WoW, WoW, genau.
Das hat die Leute dann irgendwie auch total mitgerissen, weil...
Und das kann ich ja in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch nachvollziehen.
Wenn du dann die ganze Zeit in dieser Welt abhängst, insbesondere in so einer
Multi-User, Multiplayer,
Online-Welt, da bist du ja dann quasi mit deinen Freunden unterwegs.
Also deinen Online-Freunden, deinen Game-Freunden.
Und da gilt natürlich wie im richtigen Leben auch so dieses Show what you got.
Und irgendwie du hast deinen Style und du willst dich irgendwie ein bisschen anders machen.
Im Rahmen des Möglichen und Individualisieren, so wie du das mit Klamotten machst,
bis du das dann halt auch in der virtuellen Welt machst.
Im Nachgang für mich nachvollziehbar, hätte ich jetzt so nicht vorhergesehen,
dass da wirklich so ein Trend wird, also auch so ein Trend, der so finanziell relevant ist.
Und dann ist das mit diesen Dance Moves im Prinzip ein ähnlich gelagertes Teil.
Weißt du, was ich wirklich nicht vorhersehen konnte und was ich auch bis heute
noch nicht ganz mir mir vorstellen kann.
Man kann mit Spielen Geld verdienen, okay.
Man kann mit Schühchen, Jacken oder Tänzchen in den Spielen Geld verdienen.
Aber man kann weltbekannt damit werden, dass man sich auf YouTube beim Spielen zugucken lässt.
Das ist mir wirklich nicht klar geworden. Das habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden.
Dieses ganze Let's Play, also jemand anders dabei zugucken, wie der so ein Spiel
spielt, allenfalls ja, okay, Portal 1 und 2 habe ich auch gespielt, das ist ja auch absolute.
Also da erkenne ich auch an den kulturellen Schaffenswert und so,
das ist auch wert meine Zeit darin versenkt zu bekommen und manchmal bin ich
irgendwie in Portal 2 an irgendein blödes Level geraten wo ich einfach den Ausgang
nicht gefunden habe oder nicht wusste, wie man das jetzt löst und dann guckst
du halt auf YouTube, was weiß ich,
guckst du mal eben an der Stelle wieder einer, wie dieses Jahr einer rübergesprungen
ist, damit du jetzt weiterkommst.
Aber, dass sich Leute, dass man damit berühmt und reich wird,
dass man diese Spiele spielt, weil es ausreichend Publikum in Millionenzahl
gibt, die einem dabei zugucken, wie man ein Computerspiel spielt,
das ist mir wirklich nicht klar.
Klar, also das habe ich, verstehe ich wirklich, also ich habe so ein bisschen
Vorbehalte allzu viel Computer zu spielen, aber ich habe auf jeden Fall,
so meine Grenze ist erreicht,
wenn ich jetzt sage, meine Zeit soll dafür drauf gehen, jemand anders dabei
zuzuschauen, wie er seine Zeit damit verbringt, das habe ich nicht.
Vielleicht sollte man mal, vielleicht sollte man was daraus machen,
dass man mir wiederum dabei zuguckt, wie ich wiederum jemandem zugucke,
vielleicht ist da auch noch was drin, vielleicht geht da noch was.
Linus reacts to. Ja, aber ich meine beim Fußballspielen und also Sport an sich
ist es ja auch so ein bisschen ähnlich.
Da schaut man ja auch Sportlern dabei zu, wie sie ihr Spiel besonders gut spielen,
was du vielleicht hobbymäßig auch spielst, weil du es so gut kannst.
Also ich denke, das hat schon so ein bisschen was davon.
Aber da gibt es Bier und Wurst. Das verstehe ich ja noch, dass Leute da hingehen.
Ja, aber ich glaube,
Naja gut, Bier und Wurst, das sind dann halt die Tänzer und die Klamotten,
die dann noch dazu verkauft werden. So läuft das.
Jetzt haben wir glaube ich genug Publikumsbeschimpfungen gemacht.
Kommen wir zum nächsten Kommentar, oder?
Ja, aber was heißt Beschimpfung? Also Leute, es ist nicht, wir sind ja,
wir feixen halt immer so ein bisschen damit rum.
Uns schon, die Dimension ist uns generell bekannt, uns sind vielleicht die Details
dann nicht so bekannt, weil wir halt da nicht so drin sind in diesen Spielwelten
und ich hab einfach Schwierigkeiten.
Immer wenn ich so ein bisschen eide vor dem Rechner und so ein bisschen digitale
Langeweile vor mich herschiebe, dann ist Gaming immer nicht so mein Default-Weg.
So andere weichen dann vielleicht auf ein Spiel aus, andere schauen sich dann
Fernsehserien an, ich tu dann andere Sachen.
Buchhaltung Ja, wenn noch was zu tun ist, das mache ich dann sehr gerne tatsächlich,
so ein bisschen die Konten pflegen und so schön ausgeglichen ist das macht natürlich
Spaß aber ich habe in den letzten Jahren zum Beispiel einen extremen YouTube Craze entwickelt,
da so YouTube Deep Dives zu machen und mich einfach in irgendwelche wirren,
Themen reinfallen zu lassen um einfach mal ganz neue neue Aspekte der Welt kennenzulernen.
Das funktioniert an sich auch ganz gut. Da habe ich dann irgendwie mehr Spaß
dran. Da kann ich dann mehr zu sagen.
Ja. Also ja, wir haben keine Ahnung vom Gaming.
Euer Verdacht hat sich erhärtet. Wir stehen hier mit nackter Hose im Let's Play.
So, Ralf Bendrath hat kommentiert. Ralf Bendrath,
Mitarbeiter im Europaparlament. jetzt bei Alexandra Giese hoffentlich noch.
Ist er noch da, ja.
Kurz gucken. Aber er war ja bei dem Jan-Philipp Albrecht und ist sicherlich
den meisten hier oder vielen hier bekannt aus dem Film Democracy im Rausch der Daten,
wo sie ja die DSGVO gemacht haben.
Genau, das war sein großes Ding zusammen. zusammen, Jan-Philipp Eilrecht.
Okay, und jetzt...
Hatten wir Ralf auch schon mal hier bei uns?
Ich habe totalen Quatsch erzählt. Seit November 2018 Fraktionsreferent der Fraktion
Grüne EFA im Europäischen Parlament für den Innen- und Justizausschuss.
Schwerpunkte sind weiterhin Datenschutz und digitales Überwachung,
Bürgerrechte und Sicherheit sowie polizeiliche und justizielle Zusammenarbeit.
Das ist Ralf Bernhardt. Laut seiner eigenen Homepage.
Und Alexandra Giese hat er nach der Aufstellung hier nie für gearbeitet.
Der hat mich nun mal, glaube ich, mit ihr in Kontakt gebracht.
Dann habe ich das da falsch geschlossen. Er war bis November 2018 wissenschaftlicher
Mitarbeiter von Romeo Franz und von August 2009 bis Juli 2018 der wissenschaftliche
Mitarbeiter von Jan Philipp Albrecht.
Und vor elf Jahren ist es das erste und einzige Mal bei Logbuch Netzpolitik gewesen.
So lange ist das schon her. Müssen wir ihn mal bald wieder einladen.
Und da hat er ja auch direkt uns jetzt ein Thema vorgeschlagen,
über das wir mit ihm sprechen können.
Denn er sagt, zum AI-Act und der biometrischen Überwachung des öffentlichen Raumes.
Auf welchen Text stützt sich eure Einschätzung? Nur auf den Netzpolitik-Artikel?
Es gibt noch keinen finalen Text des Gesetzes. Das kann euch einer sagen,
der in den Verhandlungen dabei ist.
Aber zur Echtzeit-RBI, so wird das da genannt, Remote Biometric Identification,
zur Echtzeit-Remote Biometric Identification, haben wir recht enge Leitplanken eingezogen. a.
Der AI-Act ist keine Rechtsgrundlage, das braucht weiterhin extra Gesetze in
den Mitgliedstaaten, die auch enge Voraussetzungen einführen dürfen. b.
Es kann nicht einfach überall und jeder gescannt werden, sondern nur nach spezifischen
Verdächtigen mit enger Begrenzung in Zeit und Raum.
C. Es braucht in jedem Fall eine vorherige Autorisierung durch ein Gericht oder
eine unabhängige Behörde, also known as Staatsanwaltschaft.
Ob das gut genug ist?
Tja, aber es ist besser, als wir zu Beginn der Verhandlungen gehofft hatten.
Die nachträgliche Auswertung von Kameraaufzeichnungen, Post-RBI,
wird gerade noch auf technischer Ebene aufgeräumt.
Das ist noch eine andere Baustelle. Grundsätzlich hat der AI-Act noch zig andere Parameter.
Ich bin daher gespannt auf eure spätere Einschätzung zum Big Picture.
Ich selber habe noch nie an so einem komplexen Gesetz mitgearbeitet.
Oh shit, das sagt Ralf Bentrath, der das wirklich lange macht.
Das macht Sorge. Also ja, Aufklärung von Ralf. Erstens gibt Echtzeit biometrische
Identifikation und nachträgliche biometrische Identifikation.
Bei der Echtzeit darf nur nach spezifischen Verdächtigen gesucht werden,
in enger Begrenzung in Zeit und Raum.
Das heißt also, es dürfen alle
Gesichter verarbeitet werden und mit den Gesuchten abgeglichen werden.
Das würde also idealerweise eine technische Lösung ermöglichen,
in der dein Gesicht nur mit dem Verdächtigen abgeglichen wird und wenn du das
nicht bist, dann eben verworfen wird.
Und das gibt es nur mit Richterin, Vorbehalt oder Anordnung der Staatsanwaltschaft.
Das klingt schon mal nach einer relativ sinnvollen Einschränkung,
die eine Massenüberwachung und Echtzeitidentifikation des öffentlichen Raumes
grundsätzlich erstmal gut einschränken sollte.
Gleichzeitig aber natürlich trotzdem, es ist eine biometrische Überwachung und
insbesondere die nachträgliche wird noch geklärt.
Das heißt, es könnte also sein, dass du nachträglich vollständig identifiziert
werden darfst, wenn das noch nicht vollständig geklärt ist.
Dann ist nur der Echtzeitteil limitiert, der es ohnehin, ich würde vermuten,
erstmal auf mittlere Dauer ohnehin ist,
weil es gibt ja dann doch eine ganze Menge Gesichter, mit denen man abgleichen
würde und würde ich erwarten, dass das Echtzeit nicht überall die ganze Zeit möglich wäre.
Aber ja, danke Ralf und man kann sich schon mal warmlaufen, wenn da bei euch
mal der Gesetzestext steht.
Wenn du sagst, das ist eines der komplexesten Dinge, an denen du je mitgearbeitet
hast, dann kannst du uns das mal erklären.
Genau.
Dann haben wir zur App Store Diskussion Kommentare.
Da haben wir auch keine Ahnung.
Ja, ne, da gibt es also von Jalma einen Kommentar, den ich mir nachher auch
ein bisschen geschrieben habe.
Zum Thema App Store. Es wurden einige Leistungen der Store-Betreiber aufgeführt,
für die ich als Kunde auch sehr dankbar bin.
Wo aber in meinen Augen ein riesengroßes Problem liegt, ist das Monopol auf In-App-Zahlungen.
Das ist der Grund, warum man zum Beispiel kein Netflix-Abo in der App abschließen
kann, sondern sich nur einloggen kann, weil Apple, Google sonst 30% vom Abo kassiert.
Dass das vollkommen absurd ist, wird vermutlich jede so sehen.
Vielen Dank für den Podcast.
Ja, und da ist genau der Punkt, den wir erstens zu wenig behandelt haben und
um den es auch in dieser Epic-Google-Auseinandersetzung geht.
Ich habe das zwar in der letzten Folge auch benannt, aber wir haben es nicht
ausreichend erklärt, dass nämlich die Diskussion darum geht,
dass sie die Bereitstellung App Store an die Nutzung dieses Payment-Systemes
binden und am Ende der Streit über In-App-Payments auch läuft.
Und eine lange Zeit, ich weiß nicht, bei Android war es sicherlich anders,
da gab es das sicherlich früher, aber ich weiß, dass irgendwann die Einführung
von In-App-Payments eine besondere Neuerung in den App-Stores war.
Und die hat natürlich auch die Kultur, wie dort Programme angeboten werden,
massiv verändert. verändert.
Ursprünglich konntest du da eine Software kaufen, die hat dann einfach einen
Betrag gekostet, fertig.
Dann gab es die Free-Version und die Pro-Version oder so.
Und jetzt gibt es aber natürlich Sachen wie, dass du Subscriptions kaufen kannst.
Du könntest also theoretisch auch also bei vielen Apps, die eine monatliche.
Dienstleistung bereitstellen, Dating-Apps haben wir ja letztes Mal besprochen,
die haben ja dann, die haben Subscriptions drin.
Oder das Spiel wird dir erstmal die ersten Erst in drei Level kannst du spielen, dann musst du bezahlen.
Derartige Dinge gibt es ja alle.
Jetzt gerade habe ich gelesen, Resident Evil 4 ist rausgekommen.
Das geht also auch los. Da kannst du ein bisschen spielen.
Und irgendwann, wenn du weiterspielen möchtest, musst du glaube ich 30 Euro zahlen oder so.
Die unterschiedlichsten Modelle, wie du quasi initial die App ohne Bezahlung
bekommst und dann nachzahlst, wurden ermöglicht.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Position der App-Store-Betreiber,
dass sie sagen, naja, in dem Moment, wo wir euch sagen,
ihr könnt was kostenlos bereitstellen und danach auf andere Wege bezahlen lassen,
ist ja klar, dass ihr gar nichts mehr an uns zahlt, weil dann wird jede Anbieterin
ihre App da bereitstellen und dann sagen,
so und damit das hier weiterläuft, musst du halt nachher auf einem anderen Kanal bezahlen.
Das haben die natürlich dann versucht zu verhindern und genau daran haben sich
aber dann hier auch Epic und so mit den App-Store-Betreibern angelegt.
Das Netflix-Beispiel ist natürlich wirklich eines der besten,
um das zu zeigen, weil es relativ klar ist, dass die Netflix-App eine verhältnismäßig einfache App ist.
Sie ist am Ende eine kleine App, die Videostreams von Netflix holt.
Und der große Wert der Dienstleistung,
die große Wertschaffung von Netflix stattfindet erstens in dem Produzieren dieser
Sendungen Und zweitens natürlich auch in dem Stream dieser Sendung von den eigenen
Servern. Das machen sie ja nicht über die Apple-Server.
Insofern wäre es schon relativ schwer nachvollziehbar, dass Netflix jetzt 30%
bezahlen sollte an Apple, nur weil der Kauf der Dienstleistung Netflix über
den Store von Apple stattgefunden hat.
Deswegen danke für den Kommentar.
Einfach nicht ausreichend beim letzten Mal rausgearbeitet.
Kommentiert der große Hobbit, unter Android ist es seit jeher möglich,
sowohl beliebige Applikationen direkt als APK aus beliebigen Quellen zu installieren,
als auch alternative Stores zu installieren, welche völlig am Google Play Store
vorbei arbeiten und auch kostenpflichtige Apps ohne Google-Abrechnung anbieten können.
So gibt es zum Beispiel den Amazon App Store, in welchem Apps kostenpflichtig
verkauft werden, den beliebten alternativen F-Droid Store für freie Open-Source-Software
und auch zahlreiche Mobiltelefonhersteller wie Samsung oder Xiaomi haben eigene Store-Lösungen.
Es ist lediglich einmal die Option zu setzen, dieser Quelle die Installation
zu erlauben, dann funktioniert es völlig transparent.
Hier wurde auch nicht ein Modell gewählt, wo man Benutzer wegen unliebsamer
Entscheidungen permanent gängelt, wie es zum Beispiel Microsoft gerne macht,
wenn man statt Edge einen anderen Browser verwenden möchte. Richtig, stimmt.
Argumentation ist aber, macht keine Sau. Also von unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern natürlich jede.
Ich habe auch auf meinem Android-Telefon ein F-Droid. Ich habe sogar Apps im
F-Droid-Store, zwei Stück und im Google Play Store.
Aber der Zugang zu diesen Apps über den Google Play Store macht 99% aus.
Deswegen also auch hier nochmal die Anmerkung, der Google Play Store beherrscht
den Markt der App Stores in Android-Land und dadurch,
dass sie den an eine bestimmte Payment-Modell binden, das ist der Teil,
um den es darum besonders geht.
Google hat aber natürlich auch in der Auseinandersetzung gegen Google gesagt,
hier, die Leute können sich doch andere Apps auf verschiedenste Wege auf dieses Gerät bringen.
Google hat dann auch in diesem Verfahren gesagt, hier, es gibt doch diese unterschiedlichen
App-Stores und man kann auch direkt über ADB die Apps installieren und so weiter,
wir zwingen doch niemanden dazu, unseren App-Store zu nutzen.
Außerdem sagen sie, es gibt auch irgendwie die Google User Choice Billing Program.
Da ist aber das Gericht eben nicht von überzeugt, dass das tatsächliche Alternativen
sind, die eher so eine, sagen, das ist eher so eine Fake Choice.
Und das Gericht hat eben selber, also ich kann auch nur das Urteil hier wieder
geben, das Gericht hat eben gesagt, nee, ihr habt hier eine marktbeherrschende
Stellung und die Verbindung mit der Bezahlmöglichkeit, insbesondere dann auch
für In-Apps, ist nicht in Ordnung.
Aber das hätten wir besser herausarbeiten können.
Ja, das ist auch ein schwierig zu lösendes Problem. Also wie man das nun eigentlich
genau gestalten kann, dass hier alle Beteiligten glücklich werden.
Weil auf der anderen Seite bergen ja diese ganzen Pay-Later-Systeme mit In-App-Purchases
genau dieses Problem auch,
dass so dann eben auch alle nicht zu Ende gedachten, dass das raus ist in den Kommentaren.
Und dann haben wir noch was falsch gemacht bei den Push-Tokens. Da kommentiert Julian.
In der letzten Folge fand ich es etwas unglücklich, dass zwei Probleme von Push-Notifications
vermischt wurden, während das eigentliche Problem nicht erwähnt wurde.
Die eigentliche Problematik, um die es gerade geht, auf den Messenger-Servern
liegen die sogenannten Push-Tokens im Klartext und können an Behörden rausgegeben werden.
Durch diese können Nutzer von anonymen Accounts über den Umweg Google bzw.
Apple de-anonymisiert werden.
Dieser Mechanismus ist bis dato recht unterbeleuchtet, aber das Ausmaß der Überwachung,
die dadurch stattfindet, wird in dem kürzlich erschienenen Reuters-Artikel nochmals
deutlich. Wir haben auch einen Blogpost gemacht.
So, Thema oder Hintergrund ist hier.
Du hast deinen Apple-Account und jetzt sind Push-Tokens von unterschiedlichen
Services, sind natürlich unterschiedlich.
Also jeder Service, der sagt, ich möchte dem Linus Push-Notification schicken,
kriegt dafür einen anderen Token.
Aber Apple hat diese Tokens alle einem Account zugeordnet.
Und jetzt können die quasi hingehen und sagen,
du registrierst dir dein Signal auf eine Telefonnummer von einer Telefonzelle
oder auf eine Wegwerfs-SIM oder die du irgendwie auf dem Boden gefunden hast
und du hast quasi keine direkt an dich,
du hast vollständig anonyme Registrationsdaten.
Zufälliger Nutzername, Wegwerf-E-Mail-Adresse und so weiter.
Installierst es aber auf deinem iPhone, was irgendwie einen Account haben muss
zum App Store, damit du nämlich dieses Ding herunterladen konntest.
Und dieser App Store ist im Zweifelsfall vielleicht sogar an eine Payment-Option gebunden.
Und jetzt sagen sie, das Problem der De-Anonymisierung entsteht für deinen vollständig
anonymen Signal oder Wire oder Telegram-Account,
wo du dir viel Mühe gegeben hast,
dadurch, dass der Push-Token am Ende doch an deine Apple-ID gebunden ist.
Ja, auch das haben wir nicht so gut herausgearbeitet.
Übrigens, was wir auch vergessen haben zu erwähnen oder ich vergessen habe zu
erwähnen ist, dass Apple A darüber jetzt Transparenz schafft und B auch sagt,
wenn wir sowas rausgeben sollen, solche Informationen,
dann wollen wir bitteschön einen richterlichen Beschluss haben.
Ja, das ist für die natürlich auch unangenehm. Also das wollen sie ja eigentlich auch nicht.
In dem Fall müsste halt Apple, so die Argumentation von Julian,
müsste halt Apple die Architektur ändern und sagen, naja, da müssen wir dafür
sorgen, dass die Push-Token so sind, dass wir die nicht mehr bei uns einer Apple-ID zuordnen können.
Ich bin mir nur nicht so sicher, ob das so ohne weiteres funktioniert. Funktioniert.
Also das kann funktionieren, aber wenn dieser Push-Notification-Service im Prinzip
doppelblind ist, weiß ich nicht.
Und am Ende könnten sie es immer noch an IP-Adressen mappen oder so.
Also ich bin mir sicher, dass man ein sehr kompliziertes Verfahren bauen kann,
dass die Push-Tokens nicht mehr unbedingt an eine Apple-ID gebunden werden können.
Aber Ich meine am Ende Push Notification ist der Sinn dieser Push Notification
ist, dass du auf deinem Telefon in deinem Account diese Informationen bekommst,
also du brauchst einfach diese Verbindung dazu,
das liegt in der Natur der Sache, da kannst du jetzt viel Verschlüsselung hinzufügen,
um dann die eigentlichen Daten, die da übertragen werden die dann halt zu schützen,
dass man sagt okay, Push Notification ja,
aber nur mit Krypto-Pflicht was natürlich dann für viele Anwendungen die Sache
auch wiederum sehr aufwendig macht für die die App-Developer,
weil die ja dann sozusagen,
dasselbe Schema wie das Signal macht etc.
Mit, ich lasse mich nur über die Push-Notification benachrichtigen,
dass etwas vorliegt, aber nicht die eigentliche Nachricht wird übertragen,
sondern nur die Information, dass da etwas ist.
Das ist ja aber das andere Problem. Das Problem, was Julian hier beschreibt, ist, dass,
angenommen meine Signal-Account wäre auf eine anonyme Telefonnummer registriert,
könnte man trotzdem meine Apple-ID quasi quasi mit Hilfe des Push-Tokens bei
Signal auf meine Apple-ID bei Apple schließen und damit potenziell meinen anonym
geglaubten Signal-Account doch noch demaskieren.
Also die Idee ist sozusagen, es nicht mehr an den Account zu binden,
sondern nur an dieses Telefon selbst.
Ja gut, aber Push-Notifications funktionieren ja dann auf all deinen Geräten
und sind ja in dem Sinne gar nicht an ein Gerät gebunden.
Also ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass man das machen kann.
Ich glaube aber dann wärst du spätestens so weit, dass du auf beiden Seiten
nicht mehr gucken kannst, ob jemand überhaupt berechtigt ist,
diese Push-Notifications zu bekommen.
Mit anderen Worten könntest du den Service massenhaft benutzen für alles mögliche
oder so Müsste man noch ein bisschen drüber nachdenken Ich glaube,
da geht eine Architektur, aber ich glaube auch nicht dass Apple die umsetzen wird, ehrlich gesagt,
Wird man sehen Ich habe Fanpost bekommen Ich habe richtig geile Fanpost bekommen,
das war die geilste Fanpost, die ich bekommen habe in dem ganzen Jahr,
Aber natürlich nicht für Logbook-Netzpolitik Nee Nee, sondern für Markus Lanz.
Ich hatte ja erwähnt, dass wir bei Markus Lanz über Zukunft gesprochen hatten.
Carla Reemsma, Florence Gaup und Raphael Laguna de la Vera.
Die Sendung wurde am 19. Dezember ausgestrahlt.
Und am 20. Dezember um halb zwei Uhr nachts erreicht mich dann,
oder war das am 18. Dezember?
Wurde die ausgesendet, erreicht mich folgende E-Mail über mein Kontaktformular.
Sehr geehrter Herr Lanz.
Warte mal, über dein Kontaktformular?
Ja, ich habe ja ein Kontaktformular auf meiner Webseite, kann man was reinschreiben.
Drückst du auf Absenden, dann kriegst du eine E-Mail.
Und dann wirst du mit Herr Lanz angeschrieben.
Ja, genau. Pass auf. Sehr geehrter Herr Lanz, wir dachten, wir hören nicht richtig.
Ihr Gesprächsteilnehmer Linus
Neumann sprach in ihrer Sendung völlig daneben und primitiv von geil.
Sie und ihre... Geil, oder? Geil, oder?
Wird noch besser. Sie und ihre Gesprächsteilnehmer haben diese sexuelle Vulgärsprache,
kommentarlos in ihrer Sendung hingenommen.
Man könnte annehmen, dass hier geil als primitiver Ersatz für andere mögliche
Ausdrucksweisen gesellschaftsfähig gemacht werden soll.
Wir Zuschauer stellen hiermit dem Herrn Linus Neumann folgende Frage.
Sind sie auch so geil wie ihre Sprache?
Ich würde sagen ja. Ich würde sagen ja.
Zweite Frage. Könnte es sein, dass sie bei Markus Lanz sexuell erregt waren?
Ich würde sagen, könnte sein, halte ich aber für äußerst unwahrscheinlich.
Hätte man vielleicht gesehen, könnte ich jetzt so sagen.
Aber insofern würde ich das eigentlich nach längerer Überlegung würde ich sagen, nein.
Also könnte sein, war aber nicht so. Und dann, dritte Frage.
Haben sie einen Hoch bekommen und vielleicht sogar einen Samenabgang?
Solches E-Mail schreibt ihr ZDF-Publikum nach zum halb zwei.
Kannst du dir das vorstellen?
So der Name des Absendenden und Mitstreiter. Wobei ich nicht weiß,
ob der wirklich seine Mitstreiter nach zum halb zwei noch mobilisiert hat.
Oder vielleicht noch, so und dann hat er da drunter, stand da,
für Herrn sowieso, das war wohl sein Assistenz, bitte weiterleiten an Herrn
Markus Lanz und die Gesprächsteilnehmer, Linus Neumann, Chaos Computer Club Berlin,
Florence Gaub, Klammer auf, E-Mail-Fragezeichen und Sprint, Raphael Laguna de
la Vera, jeweils mit Adresse, ja, also Direktor der Bundesagentur für Sprunginnovation
Leipzig und so mit Adresse.
Da muss jetzt irgendein armer Assistent, musste dann am 20.
Dezember die E-Mail ausdrucken.
Nachts um zwei.
Ich hoffe, ich war jetzt nicht mehr im Club, aber ich hoffe tatsächlich,
dass ich das auch nochmal ausgedruckt bekommen habe per Post.
Wahnsinn.
Geil, oder? Ich meine, außerdem hast du dann so ein paar Leute,
die haben Perpetuum Mobile entwickelt.
Die schreiben dir eigentlich auch jedes Mal, wenn du bei Markus Lanz warst und
noch ein paar andere Leute.
Leute, also ich kann mich ja noch daran erinnern,
wie sich das mit dem Wort geil in Deutschland verändert hat.
Das ging nämlich von heute auf morgen.
Also tatsächlich gab es mal eine Zeit, das kann man sich heutzutage nicht mehr
so richtig vorstellen, da war das Wort geil zu sagen, wie soll ich es sagen, schwierig.
Also es war wirklich ein verpöntes Wort, was so in etwa hier in dieser E-Mail
geschilderten Konnotation von Leuten verstanden wurde.
Also es war ein schmutziges Wort, was nichtsdestotrotz natürlich von der Jugend
auch kräftig benutzt wurde.
Und das alles änderte sich 1986, im April 1986,
als ein britisches Pop-Duo namens Bruce und Bongo auf die Oberfläche traten und ein Wort,
das Wort halt einfach zu einem Lied machten.
Die Single geil und wo sie also das Wort geil feierten ja sie wären ja in Deutschland
gewesen und hätten das erfolgreichste Wort Deutschlands gelernt und es wäre
geil und alles war geil Affentitten geil, super geil,
und das das war so krass zu spüren damals wie dadurch sich auf einmal alles
änderte in puncto auf dieses Wort also es war dann einfach weg weg.
Es war dann einfach nicht mehr böse.
Es war irgendwie geil, war einfach normal, akzeptiert und so weiter.
Aber es war wirklich, durch dieses eine Lied gab es diesen Durchbruch.
Es war dann irgendwie 15 Wochen lang in den Charts auf Platz 1.
Das hat dir, das muss dem guten Absender hier irgendwie verloren gegangen sein.
Ja, also der steckt dann sozusagen... Da war der wahrscheinlich gerade zu geil.
Der hat einen Lachenabgang gehabt.
37 Jahre ist das jetzt hier. 37 Jahre. Leute, wirklich, kommt mal klar.
Aber ich glaube, du bist schon ein bisschen erregt, wenn du im Fernsehen bist,
oder? Findest du schon geil, oder?
Ich find's, ich find's, also ich find's geil, dass ich danach solche E-Mails krieg.
Aber ich hab noch mehr, ich hab noch mehr, aber ich wollte jetzt nicht alle,
aber diese fand ich einfach zu geil.
Es ist doch erstaunlich, die Wahrnehmung von Fernsehen, ja, dass die immer noch so krass ist.
Ich meine, äußerst sich ja nun wirklich auch über alle denkbaren Medien,
aber dieses Auftreten in Fernsehsendungen, das hat irgendwie nochmal was ganz Besonderes.
Da musst du dann auf einmal mal vollkonform sein.
Also es gibt tatsächlich viele Reaktionen auf so eine Sendung. Und die erste,
Reaktion, also diese Land-Sendung, die wurde ausgestrahlt am 19. Dezember um 23.15 Uhr.
Und um 23.23 Uhr, also acht Minuten in die Sendung rein, hatte ich die erste E-Mail.
Mit freundlichen Grüßen. Glauben Sie wirklich, was Sie sagen?
Sagen, la la la la la, kümmern sich um die aktuelle Schulsituation.
Bist du in acht Minuten schon zu Wort gekommen?
Ich glaube, ich wurde eingangs kurz was gefragt und da habe ich gesagt,
Deutschland ist gemütlich und arrogant geworden.
Das war dann auch in der Bild-Zeitung auf bild.de. Also ich meine,
das könnte natürlich auch nochmal ein bisschen was erklären,
was dann am 20. im Laufe des Tages noch an E-Mails kam.
In der Bild-Zeitung.
Die Zeitung hat geschrieben, dass du gesagt hast, dass Deutschland arrogant geworden ist.
Deutschland ist gemütlich und arrogant geworden. Zukunftsdiskussion bei Lanz.
Haben sie ein Bild von mir, haben sie auch, glaube ich, absichtlich kein gutes genommen.
Dafür hielt sich das noch ein bisschen in Grenzen.
Die Leute werden einfach sofort getriggert.
Ja, ich sag mal so, die Leute aus meinem Freundeskreis, die mich nicht auf die
Lanz-Sendung, sondern auf die Bild-Zeitung angesprochen haben.
Die habe ich auch mit einem kleinen Kommentar im Adressbuch jetzt versehen,
weil das war, Achtung, treibt sich auf bild.de rum.
Da will man natürlich auch aufpassen, dass er nicht als nächstes,
was die Leute als nächstes sich im Internet angucken.
Aber es stimmt doch auch, Deutschland ist ja auch gemütlich ein Auge gang geworden.
Ja, haben wir auch viel Recht gegeben.
Ja.
Hacker Mund tut Wahrheit kund.
Das sowieso. Naja, ich fand auf jeden Fall diese E-Mail geil,
wollte ich mal verlesen.
So, dann haben wir eine neue Einfach nur geil. Einfach nur geil.
Super geil.
Zum 37C3 habe ich auch eine neue, gute Nachricht. Und zwar wird,
Der Eröffnungsvortrag am 27.12. um 10 Uhr. Also der Eröffnungsvortrag ist der
erste Vortrag nach der Eröffnung.
Also die Eröffnung ist um 10.30 Uhr und dann geht der erste Vortrag quasi beim 37C3 in Saal 1,
wird von niemand geringerem gehalten als von Philipp Ruch und Stefan Pelzer
über das AfD-Verbot und die Deepfakes und so weiter.
Und ich würde sagen, da kann man sich auf jeden Fall freuen und sollte früh
da sein, um diesem Fest noch einmal beizuwohnen.
Da wird noch einiges gerade vorbereitet, was viel Spaß machen könnte.
Später ist dann, hatte ich glaube ich letztes Mal schon erwähnt, auch am 27.13.
Um 13.50 Uhr ist dann der Thomas Lohninger da mit Utbaff Tiwari über diese ganzen
E-ID-Geschichten und ich glaube ich hatte auch schon erwähnt,
um 17.15 Uhr sind dann Kai Biermann und ich da,
Fulminanter Auftakt aber dass das ZPS da ist das freut mich sehr und das ZPS
auch, die freuen sich auch ein Loch im Bauch,
Ja, ich mache keinen Vortrag.
Mich findet ihr dann irgendwo in den Gängen oder im Sendezentrum vielleicht.
Im Sendezentrum, ja. Wir können Podcast machen.
Ja, nicht um Podcast zu machen, einfach um ein bisschen rumzuhacken.
Hui, hui, hui.
Hast du auch ein festes Büro auf dem Kongress, wo man vorstellen werden kann?
Ein festes Hotelzimmer.
Potenziell wäre der Presseraum ja meine Stelle, an die ich wahrscheinlich öfter
mal laufen muss. Zumindest an Tag 1 oder so.
Und ansonsten habe ich ein Hotelzimmer und werde mal gucken, wo ich da rumhänge.
Aber Zimmernummer willst du jetzt nicht sagen?
Weiß ich noch nicht. Und die sagen zu mir, wenn ich da einziehe, ist...
Das sagen wir dann durch.
So, dann gibt es eine etwas komische Meldung aus Großbritannien.
Und zwar gibt es ja diese Hackergruppe Lapsus, Lapsus, Lapsus Dollar,
die wirklich eine ganze Reihe an Unternehmen gehackt haben.
Uber, Nvidia, Rockstar Games, die Hersteller von GTA und Red Dead Redemption.
Ich streue jetzt hier am Rande immer mein Gamer-Knowledge. Das merkst du, ne?
Ja, total.
Ein paar Titel von GTA, Rockstar Games und so.
Alte mit GTA haben die auch aufs iPad gebracht.
Und, tja, der ist halt, also einer der, eines der Mitglieder dieser Gruppe,
Arion Kurthai oder Kurthasch wahrscheinlich, Arion Kurthasch,
ich weiß nicht, wie man den Namen ausspricht,
einer der bekanntesten oder wichtigsten Mitglieder dieser Gruppe,
hatte dann irgendwie schon mit 18 die Polizei an den Fersen, ja.
Die haben ihn quasi, sie wussten, wer er ist und sie wollten ihm da ein Strafverfahren zuführen,
weil die angeblich viele Millionen Dollar Schaden verursacht haben, die Lapsus.
Und jetzt sollte im Rahmen eines Gerichtsverfahrens seine Verhandlungsfähigkeit geprüft werden.
Das ist relativ üblich, gerade wenn jetzt ein 18-Jähriger, der noch dazu Autist
ist, dann gibt es natürlich erstmal
so Fragen, ist der überhaupt verhandlungsfähig, ist der schuldfähig,
wie ist die Rückfallgefahr einzustufen, das sind so klassische Fragen der forensischen Psychiatrie.
Die sich natürlich insbesondere dann stellen,
wenn die Täter jung sind, also irgendwo sich vielleicht auch die Frage stellt,
ob die zwischen Jugendstrafrecht und Erwachsenenstrafrecht liegen und jetzt
hier, wenn der sogar noch eine Diagnose hat,
dann muss natürlich erst recht die Bedeutung dieser Diagnose für die.
Justiz geprüft werden durch eben Leute, die dafür geeignet sind oder ausgebildet sind.
Und jetzt ist der forensische Psychiater zu dem Ergebnis gekommen,
der ist hoch motiviert weiterzumachen und er hat quasi keinerlei Einsicht gezeigt
oder keinerlei Absicht gezeigt, dass er jetzt weniger hacken möchte in Zukunft. Zukunft.
Und jetzt muss man ja sagen, der Typ ist halt auch tatsächlich offenbar ziemlich gut,
weil er war quasi schon unter polizeilicher Aufsicht in einem Hotel untergebracht
und da ist es ihm gelungen, dann Rockstar Games zu hacken und zwar mit einem Fire TV Stick,
dem Hotelfernseher und seinem Smartphone.
Ja, das war alles, was er hatte.
Und damit hat er dann Rockstar Games gebreached und hatte über 90 Clips aus
Videos geleakt oder denen gestohlen und hat dann in den Company Internal Slack geschrieben,
er würde also jetzt erwarten, dass sie ihn kontaktieren, sonst veröffentlicht er den Source Code.
Ich meine, der Source-Code ist natürlich relativ viel Geld wert für Rockstar
Games und das ist, sagen wir mal, so eine Drohung kannst du eigentlich nicht
aussprechen, ohne dann natürlich verhaftet zu werden.
Vor Gericht wurde aber jetzt argumentiert, nun ja, der Trailer zu GTA 6 wurde
jetzt kürzlich veröffentlicht, der hatte innerhalb von vier Tagen 128 Millionen Aufrufe,
hat glaube ich verschiedene YouTube-Rekorde gebrochen, quasi das Video mit den
am schnellsten ansteigenden View-Scouts und so weiter.
Also sagt die Verteidigung, hat er jetzt wohl nicht so einen hohen Schaden angerichtet.
Das krasse ist aber, dass der Richter jetzt gesagt hat, okay,
wenn der hoch motiviert ist und besonders gefährlich aufgrund seiner Fähigkeiten,
dann kommt er jetzt lebenslang in die Psychiatrie, bis ihn die Ärzte ihn ungefährlich einstufen.
Mit der Argumentation, seine Fähigkeiten sind ein hohes Risiko für die Öffentlichkeit
und er ist motiviert, weiterhin kriminell zu handeln.
Das ist schon ein bisschen, also das ist auch ein bisschen übel, ne?
Einen 18-Jährigen zu lebenslanger Psychiatrie zu verurteilen,
bis Ärzte ihn ungefährlich einstufen.
Der ist völlig unangemessen.
Leider gibt es viel zu viele Beispiele in den Gerichtsentscheidungen in den
USA, die halt einfach immer von Strafe… Großbritannien in dem Fall.
Ach in Großbritannien war das.
Ich glaube Oxford ist Großbritannien.
Ja, das letzte Mal als ich gecheckt habe war das Großbritannien.
Okay, das überrascht mich ja jetzt nochmal doppelt, weil das ist ja dann mega krass. Aha.
Also in Deutschland, ich kenne die britischen Gesetzgebungen nicht,
ich habe ja aber forensische Psychiatrie studiert, insofern kenne ich damit
zumindest in Deutschland ein bisschen aus.
Das wäre dann irgendwas zwischen Sicherheitsverwahrung, also du kannst natürlich Leute,
also wenn du sagst, die Person ist gefährlich, dann kannst du,
und das ist auch nicht unumstritten, gerade in Deutschland nicht,
Du könntest jemanden beispielsweise für Mord verurteilen und dann kannst du erwarten,
dass die Person vielleicht so nach 15 Jahren mit guter Führung rauskommt.
Und dann kannst du aber anschließende Sicherheitsverwahrung anordnen.
Und diese Sicherheitsverwahrung kannst du potenziell tatsächlich lebenslänglich
machen. Und diese Maß, das ist aber dann eine Anordnung der Gefahrenabwehr.
Das heißt, die gilt dann so lange, wie davon auszugehen ist,
dass von dieser Person eine Gefahr ausgeht.
Potenziell würde man sowas bei Sexualstraftätern machen, bei denen eine sehr
hohe Wiederholungsgefahr besteht.
Dann sagt man, den halten wir lieber ein Leben lang auch gegen seinen Willen
in einer psychiatrischen Anstalt, als dass wir den jetzt quasi rauslassen.
Ist aber natürlich juristisch ein riesiges Problem, weil diese Anordnung,
jemanden ein Leben lang in einer Psychiatrie oder in einer geschlossenen Anstalt zu halten,
natürlich einem Freiheitsentzug gleichkommt, hier aber eben anders begründet wird.
Also nicht eine Strafe, die dann irgendwann abgesessen ist oder so,
sondern potenziell lebenslänglich, gleichzeitig dann aber von irgendwelchen
forensischen Psychiatern die Rückfallwahrscheinlichkeit geprüft werden soll.
Und jetzt kannst du dir vorstellen, welchen Bias hast du wohl eventuell als
forensischer Psychiater,
der eine potenziell gemeingefährliche Person beurteilt, die mehrere sexuelle
Straftaten begangen hat und jetzt musst du die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass die wieder straffällig wird, einschätzen.
Und wenn du dann sagst, naja, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist relativ gering,
den kannst du eigentlich rauslassen und du hast dich aber leider vertan,
dann hast du natürlich für dein Leben lang diese Schuld auf den Schultern.
Während, wenn du den...
Ein Leben lang da drin lässt, obwohl du vielleicht fachlich der Ansicht bist,
der könnte vielleicht gar nicht mehr so gefährlich sein, dann hast du diese Last auf den Schultern.
Und wie gesagt, das Ganze bewegt sich jetzt außerhalb der normalen juristischen
Dimensionen, die wir für die Strafe haben, nämlich die Sicherheitsverwahrung.
Schon ziemlich, also ein nicht unumstrittenes Konstrukt, dass es das überhaupt gibt.
Ja und vor allem für 18-Jährige. Also ich meine, mit 18 ist man ja nun beileibe
noch nicht am Ende seiner geistigen Entwicklung angekommen.
Ich meine, ich würde sogar fast sagen, man ist eigentlich nie am Ende seiner
geistigen Entwicklung angekommen oder sollte es zumindest nicht sein.
Aber mit 18, da tut sich definitiv noch eine Menge.
Ja, ist ja noch eine steilere Kurve.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist es ja in Deutschland auch so,
dass das jetzt so gar nicht möglich wäre.
Also so lebenslang für 18-Jährige wegen irgendwas ist glaube ich generell nicht
möglich im Jugendstrafrecht, oder?
Also Sicherungsverwahrung kannst
du schon potenziell erst, also potenziell unbegrenzt erstmal anordnen.
Auch für 18-Jährige?
Da käme es sicherlich darauf an, wie, das ist übrigens auch,
es kann zum Beispiel sein, dass du jemanden, also nur was theoretisch möglich ist,
du stellst fest, jemand ist nicht schuldfähig, weil der so stark verrückt ist
oder so stark von bestimmten Trieben zum Beispiel zu morden oder so oder sexuelle
Straftaten zu begehen bestimmt ist,
dass du sagst, der Person fehlt die Einsichtsfähigkeit.
Ja, die kann, du kannst ja im Prinzip noch nicht mal vorwerfen,
dass sie das tut, weil sie in dem Moment.
Die Einsicht in ihr eigenes Verhalten und seine Konsequenzen gar nicht mehr
hat, dann würdest du sagen, diese Person ist also nicht, du würdest sie potenziell
von verminderter Schuld ausgehen.
Und jetzt kannst du aber gleichzeitig sagen, weil die Person so stark in der
Kontrolle ihres Verhaltens gemindert ist, stellt sie eine Gefahr dar und deswegen
gehen wir die jetzt in Sicherungsverwahrung.
Der juristische Unterschied ist, in der einen, nur wenn du schuldfähig bist,
kannst du auch in den Knast kommen.
Wenn du nicht schuldfähig bist, dann bist du eben nicht schuldfähig und dann
greift das Konzept des Knasts nicht.
Dann gibt es quasi kein Urteil für dich, weil das Urteil an Schuld gebunden
ist und wenn du diese Schuld nicht hast,
wenn du die nicht haben kannst, dann wäre es theoretisch eben sogar möglich,
dass du nicht, quasi gar nicht bestraft wirst.
Ja, passiert natürlich, aber theoretisch wäre das möglich.
Oder beziehungsweise, das ist sogar relativ oft möglich, dass du gar nicht bestraft
wirst wegen mangelnder Schuldfähigkeit.
So, wenn das aber jetzt dann etwas ist, wo man sagt, mit dieser Disposition
seiner Persönlichkeit darf dieser Mensch eigentlich nicht auf die Allgemeinheit
losgelassen werden, weil davon auszugehen ist, dass der weiterhin,
was weiß ich, mordet oder sonst was.
Dann könntest du quasi sagen, die Person ist nicht schuldfähig,
aber kommt in eine Sicherungsverwahrung.
Gut, jetzt haben wir natürlich in diesem Fall keinen Mord.
Und weil die Sicherungsverwahrung, ganz kurz, weil die Sicherungsverwahrung
nicht an Schuld gebunden ist, sondern an die Tatsache, dass du eine Gefahr darstellst,
ist es dann eben möglich, dass die langfristig ist.
Ja, so viel zum allgemeinen Konstrukt des Unterschiedes zwischen diesen beiden.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich in diesem Fall nicht Mord und Totschlag,
sondern Hackerei und so ein Zwang zur Veröffentlichung.
Keine Ahnung, was ihm da jetzt im Einzelnen genau attestiert wurde.
Es heißt ja Autist, das kann ja auch alles mögliche bedeuten.
Kann vor allem bedeuten, dass da auch einfach ja nochmal ganz andere Kräfte
am Start sind, die vielleicht auch in eine nicht schuldfähige Fähigkeit münden
können, so wie du das gerade formuliert hast, weiß ich nicht.
Andererseits finde ich aber jetzt so etwas, naja, was ist jetzt passiert?
Okay, es ist etwas angedroht worden, was dann nicht stattgefunden hat und es
ist ein Trailer veröffentlicht worden.
Und? Ja, das ist in meinen Augen eher Pipifax.
Also die Lapsus-Gruppe hat schon eine ganze Menge andere Dinge gemacht.
Aber die haben vor allem interessanterweise relativ viel mit Social Engineering gemacht.
Also irgendwie Spearfishing, Sim-Swapping, aber eben dann auch versucht zu erpressen.
Wen haben die alles aufgemacht? Das Gesundheitsministerium von Brasilien,
Okta, das ist so ein Identification und Authentication Provider, Nvidia, Samsung,
MercadoLibre, Ubisoft, T-Mobile, Microsoft, Globant, Uber und Rockstar Games.
Und das ist schon auf jeden Fall schon ganz gut.
Aber hauptsächlich eben durch Social Engineering. Deswegen ist er da wahrscheinlich
auch mit seinem Smartphone so weit gekommen. kommen.
Aber den wird laut dem Artikel, den wir hier verlinken, in den Shownotes halt
unterstellt, dass sie einen Schaden im Bereich von 10 Millionen verursacht haben.
Wo ich so denke, naja, also das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so viel.
Rockstar hat angegeben, dass der Hack das Unternehmen 5 Millionen Dollar gekostet habe.
Da würde ich gerne auch mal die Rechnung sehen, weil das würde mich schon interessieren,
ob das Beträge sind, die die bezahlen mussten oder ob das irgendwelche ideellen
Ideen sind, wo sie irgendwie den Wert von einem Video ansetzen.
Gleichzeitig ist unklar, ob die jemals Geld bekommen haben, also ob die sich
auch jemals wirklich bereichert haben, weil keiner zumindest zugegeben hat,
denen jemals Lösegeld gezahlt zu haben.
Gut, lass uns lieber über Porn reden. Das interessiert die Leute.
Das interessiert die Leute mehr. Die EU hat jetzt entschieden,
also Brüssel, Brüssel kennt ihr Brüssel, hat entschieden, dass jetzt einige
Pornoportale zu großen Plattformen, sehr großen Online-Plattformen deklariert werden.
Dadurch kriegen sie bestimmte Pflichten.
Also es geht nach dem Digital Services Act, den haben wir ja hier behandelt,
der großen Plattformen, den VLOPs, Very Large Online Platforms,
besondere Sorgfaltspflichten auferlegt.
Und die Kommission hat jetzt erklärt, dass diese Kategorisierung auch für Pornhub,
Stripchat und X-Videos gilt.
Denn man habe ermittelt, dass alle drei die Untergrenze von 45 Millionen monatlich
aktiven Nutzern und Nutzerinnen erfüllen.
Und damit würden sie diese Definition WLOP erfüllen und haben sich deswegen daran zu halten.
Dafür haben sie jetzt vier Monate Zeit, zum Beispiel eine Risikoanalyse in Bezug
auf illegale und grundrechtsfeindliche Inhalte durchzuführen und besondere Maßnahmen
zum Kinderschutz einzuführen.
Ich glaube, das wird nochmal unterhaltsam.
Ja. Kinderschutz bei Porn, okay.
Einfach überlegen, wie riskant ist unsere Plattform für das Hochladen illegaler Inhalte,
zum Beispiel auch hinsichtlich der Gefahr für geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt
und den Schutz von Minderjährigen und ihrer mentalen Gesundheit.
Da müssen wir also eine Risikoanalyse schreiben, warum ist das hier gefährlich
oder wie gefährlich ist das hier und was machen wir.
Was ich aber auch spannend finde ist, den Unternehmen ist es zukünftig verboten,
Werbung auf Grundlage bestimmter sensibler Daten wie sexueller Orientierung,
politische Einstellung und Religionszugehörigkeit zu personalisieren.
So, jetzt überlege ich mal bitte. Also wenn Pornhub seine Werbung nicht mehr
aufgrund der sexuellen Orientierung für dich spezialisieren darf,
dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das für einige Leute einfach echt ein viel
schlechteres Nutzungserlebnis wird mit der Werbung dort.
Ich würde jetzt schon erwarten, dass man denen erlauben könnte,
Werbung aufgrund der sexuellen Orientierung für dich zu klastern.
Ja, aber das ist verboten.
Ja, das ist vielleicht dann der Moment, wo das wirklich mal unangemessen ist,
aber so lautet dann mal das Gesetz an der Stelle.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie die sich dann noch, also das riecht nach Ärger,
würde ich sagen. Die werden sich auf jeden Fall noch mal ein bisschen zanken.
Ich frage mich, wie sich Werbung anpasst im Verhältnis zu politischer Einstellung.
Naja, also der DSA ist ja gebaut worden für große Plattformen und man sagt,
wenn die so viele Nutzerinnen und Nutzer haben, dass sie geeignet wären,
zu Manipulationen zu führen.
Und der Anwendungsfall wäre jetzt hier zum Beispiel etwas wie Facebook.
Die können mit Sicherheit aufgrund der Datenmengen und sozialen Netze,
sozialen Graphen, die sie von ihren Nutzerinnen und Nutzern haben,
mit sehr großer Validität die politische Orientierung der Nutzerinnen vorhersagen.
Die können mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen, diese Person wählt wohl
eher nicht AfD, die scheint sich für die Grünen zu interessieren,
zumindest bei vielen Leuten.
Und das dürfen sie dieses Wissen, was sie einfach haben, dürfen sie eben nicht
verwenden für zielgruppenorientierte Werbung.
Das war ja die ganze Idee oder eine der wichtigsten Ideen bei dem DSA,
dass diese großen Online-Plattformen ihr riesiges Wissen und ihr Manipulationsvermögen nur im Bereich,
wir verkaufen den Leuten Scheiß, den sie nicht brauchen, verwenden dürfen.
Aber nicht im Bereich, wir machen Werbung, wir verkaufen den Scheiß, den sie brauchen,
weil er ihrer sexuellen Orientierung entspricht und nicht, wir richten Werbung
an sie, die sich potenziell politisch.
Die ihre potenzielle politische Bedeutung hat und sich danach richtet,
welche politische Orientierung der Person hat. Einfacher gesagt, Cambridge Analytica.
Das wollen sie halt verbieten oder verhindern. Das ist jetzt erstmal auch in
Ordnung. Ja, definitiv.
Also Cambridge Analytica, wer es nicht mehr im Hinterkopf hat,
das ist halt so die große Geschichte der Beeinflussung rund um Brexit und die Trump-Wahl,
wo halt wirklich gezielt Werbung auf den Plattformen so ausgespielt wurde,
um Wähler einer bestimmten politischen Ausrichtung halt in die eine oder in
die andere Richtung zu machen.
Sprich, in den USA war es halt Republikaner gegen die Demokraten aufbringen
und die Demokraten davon abbringen zu wählen. So nach dem Motto.
Und natürlich noch viel feinerer Abstufungen, aber das war so die grobe Richtung
und beim Brexit in UK ist es halt ähnlich gelaufen.
So, was ist eigentlich hier mit unserer Lieblingsplattform Schitter oder wie man es nennen soll.
Das Interessante ist, dass irgendwie immer noch eigentlich alle Twitter sagen.
Ja, finde ich auch in Ordnung.
Ja, irgendwo nachvollziehbar. So, was ist jetzt mit Twitter?
Wir erinnern uns, dass seit einigen Wochen die Europäische Kommission,
insbesondere der Thierry Breton,
Twitter mit der Einleitung eines Verfahrens gedroht hat.
Dieses Verfahren haben sie jetzt eröffnet, wegen Verbreitung illegaler Inhalte.
Auch da unter dem DSA eine Untersuchung eingeleitet, das haben sie am Montag
mitgeteilt und sie haben nämlich eine Anfrage dahin geschickt und darauf haben
sie keine zufriedenstellenden Antworten geliefert. hat.
Lass mich raten, wahrscheinlich haben sie den Poop-Emoji bekommen,
den ja jeder kriegt, der eine Presseanfrage an Twitter schreibt.
Das trifft zusammen mit dem Leak den sogenannten X-Files.
Akte X hieß doch in den USA X-Files, oder? Der Name ist schon weg.
Der nächste, wo wo...
Es im Prinzip eine Anweisung gibt, wo den Leuten bei Twitter gesagt wird,
dass sie bestimmte Inhalte nicht mehr löschen sollen, sondern allenfalls noch Shadowbannen sollen.
Also du sagst so hier, der soll dann nicht mehr irgendwo auftauchen,
sondern nur wenn er gezielt gesucht wird, dann erscheint dieser Tweet.
Und da gab es dann Beispiele von Tweets,
die irgendwelche geschmacklosen Kommentare zu Zügen und Auschwitz hatten und
das dürfte also, sollte jetzt nicht mehr entfernt werden.
Genauso nicht Bilder von Adolf Hitler, auf denen andere Accounts verlinkt sind.
Und jetzt sollte quasi derartiges auf Twitter bestehen bleiben.
Außerdem hat Elon Musk jetzt auch den Alex Jones wieder auf die Plattform geholt.
Ein einziger Untergang.
Ja, und die beiden Dinge treffen natürlich jetzt gut aufeinander.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass diese, ach lass mal, Holocaust-Leugnung oder
Holocaust-Verharmlosung ruhig stehen,
dass das diesem Untersuchungsverfahren jetzt nicht unbedingt ausreichend entgegenwirkt.
Ne, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das jetzt ein großer Showdown
wird, weil letzten Endes natürlich auch die EU hier im Wort ist,
mal ihren DSA auch wirklich,
zur Anwendung zu bringen und auch zu zeigen, dass das was kann und ein besseres
Beispiel als das geht es ja nun eigentlich nicht.
Schlimmer kann es ja kaum noch kommen.
Und ja, wird interessant sein zu sehen, welchen Gegenwind jetzt Elon Musk noch
so aus Europa bekommen kann.
Seine Autos haben ja auch gerade etwas Probleme. Weiß nicht,
ob du das mitbekommen hast mit den Streiks in Skandinavien.
In Skandinavien streiken die, ne? Zwei Millionen von den Karimuser zurückrufen
und in Deutschland gibt es keine Förderung mehr.
Ja gut, das mit der Förderung ist glaube ich noch das geringere Problem,
aber Hauptproblem ist, dass er in Skandinavien einfach nichts ausliefern kann,
weil einfach alle Arbeiter streiken.
Er hat sich da ja gegen Gewerkschaften ausgesprochen und das ist ein sehr unpopuläres
Thema in Skandinavien. Also so gegen die Gewerkschaften vorzugehen ist schwierig.
Da hat sich ja jetzt auch so ein dänischer Politiker zu Wort gemeldet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das Video gesehen hast, wo Elon Musk kurz einblendet,
wie er meint, ja die Idee von Gewerkschaften gefällt mir nicht.
Und er so, ja, uns gefällt die auch mal super und wenn du da irgendwie nicht
mit konform gehst, dann fuck you, weißt du?
Dann spielst du halt hier nicht mehr mit. Also das wird sehr interessant sein,
generell zu sehen, weil wir natürlich jetzt hier so ein bisschen auch den Clash der Kulturen haben.
Da ist halt wirklich dieser Divide, den wir dann doch noch haben,
zwischen USA und Europa, wird sich jetzt auch beweisen müssen.
Also sowohl was jetzt die Rechte betrifft, die da im DSA,
niedergeschrieben wurden und die ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch so ein bisschen
wegweisend sein sollen für eine Regulierung des Contents im Internet auf der
einen Seite, aber eben auf der anderen Seite auch dieses,
wie gehen Unternehmen generell mit ihren Mitarbeitern um, ist natürlich bei
Twitter auch nochmal ein Thema für sich, aber,
bei Tesla dann eben auch.
Da bin ich gespannt und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das 2024 ein Jahr des
Setbacks wird für Herrn Musk.
Meinst du?
Ja.
Aber Earth wird es doch dann beurteilen.
Also dieses Video wächst auch.
Als ich das erste Mal gesehen habe, habe ich nur gedacht so,
ja, ach ja, Musk ey. Aber je öfter du dir das anguckst, merkst du halt, wie...
Meinst du jetzt dieses Interview?
Dieses Interview mit dem Times-Journalisten oder wer das da war,
wo er dann gesagt wird, ja was ist denn, hier guck mal, du willst doch mit der
Plattform schon auch Geld ein bisschen verdienen oder zumindest Geld,
also keinen Verlust machen und jetzt gehen die Leute von der Plattform weg mit
ihrer Werbung, weil du halt irgendwie Antisemitismus da zulässt, wie siehst du denn das?
Und dann sagt er irgendwie so, ja, dann mach's nicht, ich will mich von euch
nicht erpressen lassen,
ihr wollt mich mit Geld erpressen und außerdem werden alle wissen,
dass ihr damit Twitter tötet und dann wird die Welt euch richten oder sowas.
Und denkst dir so, hast du mal drüber nachgedacht, ob du vielleicht einfach
diese antisemitischen Tiraden auf deinem Twitter ein bisschen in den Griff kriegst
und dann werben die Leute auch wieder und niemand wird erpresst.
Also ich, diese Interpretation ist ihm nicht mehr so wirklich zugänglich.
Also kann man wirklich sehr empfehlen, sich mal dieses ganze Interview anzuschauen.
Wir verlinken das auch nochmal bei diesem Dealbook Summit, so hieß das. Und Und...
Ich habe wirklich starke Zweifel an seinem Gesundheitszustand,
an seinem mentalen Gesundheitszustand, weil es ist halt einfach,
mittlerweile ist er so off, das ist gar nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen.
Also, Masken-Boys müssen sich da wirklich mal fragen lassen,
was sie eigentlich an diesem Typen hier so überzeugend finden,
weil für mich wirkt der einfach instabil.
Ich meine, du bist ja Psychologe, ja, keine Ahnung, was du so für einen Eindruck
gewonnen hast aus diesem Interview, aber das wirkte auf mich schon sehr fragil, ne?
Der schläft halt nicht genug. Der ist auf jeden Fall nicht auf dem Zenit seines
Seins, würde ich mal so vorsichtig sagen.
John Oliver hat das auch nochmal so ein bisschen behandelt. Das verlinken wir
auch nochmal in den Shownotes.
Und damit verabschieden wir uns ins Lebkuchenessen.
Echt?
Ja, wir könnten noch ein Thema behandeln, aber das behandle ich dann in der nächsten Sendung.
Also es gibt gerade ein bisschen Spaß in der Ransomware-Szene,
aber ich muss ja in ein paar Tagen einen Vortrag über Ransomware halten und
dann möchte ich das lieber in meinem Vortrag verwenden und danach in Logbuch-Netzpolitik.
Aha, Zweitverwertung sozusagen, okay.
Nee, ist schon klar, du musst ja natürlich deine exklusiven Verträge mit dem CCC halten.
Ja, genau. Na dann,
blicken wir auf ein wieder mal ziemlich verrücktes Jahr zurück.
Goldene Zwanziger.
Stehen noch aus.
Ja.
Ja, es gab dann doch nicht ganz so viel Fortschritte in diesem Bereich,
wie man sich vielleicht gewünscht hätte.
Aber die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt. Ich bin aber nach wie vor sehr positiv.
Einfach, weil es einfach nicht so weitergehen kann. Dass sich weiter alles verschlimmert.
Mal gucken. Steht so einiges an. 24.
Wahlen in den USA. Wahlen im Vereinigten Königreich. Haben wir eigentlich auch Wahlen? Nee, ne?
Wir werden auch Wahlen haben. Wir werden auch Wahlen haben.
Mal gucken, ob wir Bundestagswahlen haben. Glaube ich aber jetzt mal nicht.
Also, ja doch. Ich glaube schon.
Meinst du? Regierung schafft es nicht?
Also, da muss doch wirklich jeder sich langsam denken, was soll das?
Ja gut.
Wir werden es sehen. Jetzt schauen wir erstmal, dass der Kongress ordentlich
wird und dann sehen wir weiter.
Genau.
Leute, war schön mit euch. Wir machen dieses Jahr wieder weiter.
So wird es sein.
Insofern dann,
verabschieden wir euch jetzt und sagen Tschüss. Bis bald.
Macht euch eine geile Weihnacht.
Tschüss.